coches de la policía haya agentes acerca
de la casa del expresidente de Brasil
Jair a bolsonaro el motivo una orden de
allanamiento a su casa que se saldó con
la detención de dos de sus ayudantes
como parte de una investigación que
intenta responder a una pregunta
falsificó bolsonaro los registros de
vacunación públicos Y es que a pesar de
que el expresidente de extrema derecha
ha repetido en varias ocasiones que
nunca recibió una vacuna contra el
covid-19 aparecen los registros públicos
de vacunación de noviembre de 2021 y
diciembre de 2022 supuestamente para
poder ingresar en Estados Unidos
la policía federal lanzó el miércoles la
operación veniré para esclarecer las
acciones de una asociación criminal
formada para cometer el delito de
introducción de datos falsos de
vacunación contra el covid 19 los
sistemas del Ministerio de salud como
parte del operativo la policía efectuó
16 órdenes de registro y 6 de detención
en Brasilia
de Janeiro y entre los sospechosos
estaba el propio bolsonaro a pesar de
que ha negado haber cometido cualquier
delito
no me vacuné fue decisión personal mía
después de leer el prospecto de pfizer
me sorprende una operación de registro y
una incautación Por tal motivo y no
tengo nada más que decir
esta nueva investigación pone más
presión sobre el líder de ultraderecha
brasileña que ya enfrenta otras causas
por su presión de votantes malversación
y ataques contra la legitimidad del
sistema electoral brasileño